i'm trying to piss inside my wife
[Music]
i'm mike cannon and i'm back to answer
the internet because i have a special
coming out may 18th youtube.com mike
cannon comedy white privilege homeless
would you bang your cousin to win the
powerball this is like not even a
question i would bang him or her
unprotected and would leave it in
because i can pay to have that baby
killed right before the judgment
it's got to be fast
we got about eight weeks to do this
you had to watch one category of porn
for the rest of your life what would it
be um yeah i'm sure i mean i'm amateur i
used to go to reddit homemade xxx
so that i i got shown that and it it
opened my eyes to a world
and then i stood on that for a long time
and now i'm like kind of for ease i go
to pornhub just because you know i'm
jerking between naps of my son he's like
out for 10 seconds and then i hear his
cars on the floor and i'm like gotta
finish so it's whatever i put my mouse
over and it looks good latina amateur
casting couch
yeah when it's crunch time
i know exactly who i'm giving the ball
to
is jerking off to nudes of a girl who
has died weird or a nice tribute that is
a beautiful send-off that's like putting
quarters over her eyes and pushing her
out onto a lake on a raft and then
shooting
an on-fire bow and arrow where it just
explodes in majesty um i've i've done
that i've had sex with uh with with
girls that that are dead um now
now that's clarified now dead at the
time warm bodied and breathing uh i
gotta say i sometimes go back to the
rolodex and crank one out and just
salute to the heavens right after would
you take a million dollars to be one of
the picket people for the westboro
baptist church during a fallen soldier's
funeral i mean at this point that might
be a good credit
that could fill the seats you could go
either way i could be an ultra lib [ __ ]
i just got a paper cut i'm dying or i
could just be this person at the whisper
baptist church during a fall insult yeah
yeah i've been to the middle east i feel
like i've done my due diligence on the
other side i've performed for our troops
for three thousand dollars would you get
your face photoshopped into a gay porno
yeah i mean i would uh i'm trying to
think if i would participate in a gay
porno for three thousand dollars who
needs a deep fake when i could actually
deep fake in person um yeah i would have
no problem with that especially because
you know tom cru they have those videos
of tom cruise you could just say it
wasn't you
at any point even if it is you i'd just
be like that's not me and you're like
but you're saying it's really me
it's like the austin powers penis
enlarger book it's like this sort of
thing is my bag baby
if you had the flexibility to blow
yourself
would you do it what if everybody knew
you did again i have no problem no shame
if anybody knows that i'm capable of
doing that i feel like that adds
attributes to who i am as a person if i
could i'd absolutely do it at least one
i don't think i have the like heavy
enough legs to do it you know because
you can't just
you can't fold at the waist and suck
your own dick
i mean you got to be marilyn manson then
i see what you're saying but i feel like
maybe if you do some yoga and
flexibility of your hip flexors but my
if my legs
weighed me down i'd have to put ankle
weights or something because and then
just get as close as humanly possible i
also i just i've seen how i eat a
lollipop i would not make myself calm
my dick just clacking around my molars
that would be
a true nightmare i would do it probably
at parties
if i could i'd be like guys if you want
to see something super fun i'm going to
suck my own deck i just put myself on a
glass coffee table in the middle of the
central room and i'm like all right hand
me my weights
if you had to watch your biggest enemy
[ __ ] the girl of your dreams in order
for you to marry her would you do it
absolutely not like that is like one
part of me that is so irish and insecure
i can't handle the idea of another guy
[ __ ] my wife properly you know i mean
like i can't i can't allow her to know
what else is out there i've convinced
her that this is satisfactory
and it's it's it's it's a miraculous
magic trick that i've pulled off but i
can't i can't give her one shot and then
she's like oh i don't like even though i
signed the contract we've been dating on
and off since we were 10 years old
literally we were neighbors that whole
thing it is not psychotic we both have
had hpv at one point in our lives
and uh and have probably cycled it back
and forth through each other but uh it's
uh yeah no it would be i would not want
to be her only thing she uh she actually
had a black boyfriend which i was super
proud of
because i'm still filling her up so that
feels pretty good
what's better the best [ __ ] of your life
the worst sex of your life
dude can i add to that because the best
[ __ ] of your life is so
there is an orgasmic feeling to that and
they satisf a satisfaction that doesn't
come from many other things but i've
been liking
like big pisses lately like
big i'm about to burst i feel my stomach
potentially like a seam popping and
urine flying out of my my lap
yeah dude
but when i piss i cry i it feels so good
i have tears running down my face and
i'm just like
i can't it's the best feeling i've ever
had in my entire life
i'm trying to piss inside my wife
would you rather watch a only softcore
porn for the rest of your life b only
minor league sports for the rest of your
life so this is how full circle i've
become with porn is now i watch like
scenes from shameless
instead of actual insertion porn i mean
emmy rossum is so goddamn hot and those
scenes seem so realistic that i could
get there
real easy from that [ __ ] dude i love
softcore porn huge advocate huge fan
more a-list celebrities should do it
that euphoria too
in the car with her hand on the roof and
you're just like entertaining
damn
and she's a knicks fan come on
if you saw that one of your friends
accidentally posted a dick pic on
snapchat would you tell him or let it
let him leave it up so this has happened
to me before and i let it rock for like
an hour
i watched no no i did not i found my
buddy and he just had it up and i was
like well it's a good picture like it's
not like it's not doing him any favors
it's one of those things where like you
put it out and people are probably like
well that's a great deck it's like it's
like chris evans or what jesse williams
but did you see jesse williams the dude
from grace anatomy and a video of him
naked on stage went viral and like they
interviewed about him him about it he's
like listen consent is important he's
like i don't care and when you watch the
video you're like i wouldn't care either
yeah i'd send that out to every
production house in america he's
literally like punching his duraflame
log in front of a live audience and
women are just like
in their seats
it's insane dude would you rather be
good looking and always have nice
clothes but smell like [ __ ] or look like
a homeless person but smell nice so
basically the second part is like being
an olsen twin
the way in which people dress right now
you drab yourself up and you're a
billionaire but you smell fantastic
yeah the smelling thing is what gets me
because i sweat i'm a huge sweater i
have pities right now they are intense
but i never smell so it's not a problem
but just that the knowing of that my
my body is reaching you
eight feet away that's uh that's a no-go
the amount of comedians that have
straight
halitosis in the back of their mouths
and have no idea and like try to talk
close at like a party or something like
that it's like dude you just you just
breathed awful [ __ ] up my nose from
like inches away
my eyes started twitching talking about
that i literally got too many too many
comedians just running through my head
my man mike cannon one of the most
underrated in the game make sure you
check him out and make sure you
subscribe to us here on answer the
internet make sure you click the
notification symbol and leave a comment
below on who you want to see next